in the spring of the year 1644 the
emperor of china hiked up a hill just
north of the forbidden city in beijing
as he reached the summit of prospect
hill he had a clear view of the imperial
city beneath him
but on this day his gaze would have been
fixed on the smoke and fire that rose up
from distant quarters of the capital
it was april 24th
and all that smoke and fire was the
handiwork of peasant rebels who were
about to breach the walls of the
forbidden city
julio jen the 17th and soon-to-be last
emperor of the ming dynasty climbed back
down the hill and gathered the women of
his harem around him
unwilling to let any of them be captured
alive jew made a clumsy attempt to slice
them to death
having failed to kill his family the
emperor then climbed back up the hill
and hung himself from the rafters of the
pavilion of imperial longevity
it was an ironic place for an emperor to
die much less witness the end of an
entire dynasty
surprisingly though this would not be
the last time that prospect hill would
serve as the backdrop for a dramatic
fall from political grace
on october 6 1976 more than three
centuries later chiang ching the widow
of communist revolutionary mao zedong
decided to spend the day picking fruit
on prospect hill
when she was arrested and put on trial
for her role in the cultural revolution
if it was any solace both jiang ching
and juyo jien enjoyed the best view in
all of beijing before the end came
and it is a vantage point still enjoyed
by millions of exhausted tourists who
make the hike up prospect hill each year
from the summit you can see the defining
features of the forbidden city below
a series of rectangular walled
enclosures laid out on a north-south
axis all surrounded by a moat that is 13
feet deep and 175 feet across
spread out over 178 acres are more than
a hundred buildings containing some 900
rooms nearly all of which conform to a
standard exterior color scheme
gray cobblestone courtyards
vermilion walls and golden tiled roofs
now it's easy to get lured into
complacency by the architectural
uniformity of the forbidden city many
visitors including myself many years ago
come away from their visit a little
disappointed at first
and second glance the buildings all look
superficially alike and the rich history
behind them can be overwhelming for the
casual tourist to digest
unlike other great monuments or natural
wonders that wear their beauty and
history on their sleeves the forbidden
city doesn't express its majesty by
reaching for the stars
its halls and palaces aren't larger than
life
so you won't feel like an ant walking
through its courtyards and gateways
instead the architects of the forbidden
city pursued a vision in which chinese
models of cultural harmony are endlessly
replicated with the goal of placing the
emperor at the center of the cosmos
between heaven and earth
according to liang suchang a prominent
chinese architect quote the individual
buildings especially from a structural
view are unremarkable
but as a composition of the grand plan
there is nothing comparable to it in the
world it is a grand plan on the grandest
scale
it's also really old
in fact the forbidden city just
celebrated its 600-year anniversary in
the year 2020 a remarkable feat for
densely packed wooden structures
though as you might expect many of them
have burned down and been rebuilt
multiple times in 1987 in recognition of
its status as the preeminent
architectural symbol of imperial china
the forbidden city was designated a
unesco world heritage site
with such great milestones come great
expectations
and our goal for this lecture is to
chart a unique path through the
forbidden city one that allows us to
appreciate its complex history and
design on a more intimate scale
but first let's orient ourselves
geographically
there are two major rivers in china the
yellow river in the north and the yangzi
river in the south
in more than 3 000 years of recorded
history in china the capital of every
single significant empire has been based
somewhere near the yellow river in the
north even after the majority of the
population migrated south to the yangzi
river delta during the first millennium
a.d
there's a simple reason for this the
generally flat terrain of northern china
is what some historians call an exposed
zone
exposed to what
well the nomads of inner asia in fact
most chinese dynasties weren't nearly as
chinese as you might think
roughly half the time
china was ruled wholly or in part by
northern nomadic peoples such as the
mongols and the manchus who use their
military advantages on horseback to roam
over vast distances and conquer the
fertile agricultural regions to the
south
it is also why many dynasties in china
kept trying to build imposing walls
along their northern peripheries
to provide a man-made barrier where the
terrain had not provided a natural
barrier
so the capitals of major dynasties in
china tended to be based on the north
this is because chinese dynasties needed
to keep a close watch on the northern
frontier while conquering nomads wanted
to retain close ties to their homeland
but why beijing specifically
after all the founder of the ming
dynasty julian zhang had decreed that
the capital should be in nanjing
in the south
but when the emperor died in the year
1398 his fourth son judy contested the
succession and seized the throne from
his nephew
significantly judy's base of power was
in beijing where his father had ordered
him to keep a vigilant watch over the
mongol threat
now emperor judy embarked on an
ambitious program to erase all memory of
the old capital in nanjing as well as
his own bloody ascent to power
to seal the deal he commissioned a new
palace in the new capital
the forbidden city
completed in the year 1420 the forbidden
city served as the primary residence for
24 emperors over two different dynasties
for more than 500 years it was the
backdrop for imperial ceremonies and
rituals palace intrigue and the routine
business of government but don't be
fooled by its impressive moat or its
forbidding walls for the forbidden city
was no fortress
in fact over the course of its lengthy
history the forbidden city has been
broached by invading armies on numerous
occasions
the most important one occurred in 1644
when manchu armies from the north took
advantage of the suicide of the last
ming emperor to establish their own
dynasty the qing
this means that the history of the
forbidden city is split almost evenly
between two very different types of
dynasties
a chinese one with ancestral roots in
the south and a manchu one with
ancestral roots in the inner asian step
to the north
and we will see this change in
leadership reflected in the evolving
function of many of the buildings inside
the forbidden city
it is also reflected in its plaques and
signs with many important inscriptions
written in both chinese and
manchu and the ming ching transition of
1644 was by no means the last assault on
the gates of the forbidden city
as we hike down prospect hill and cross
the moat from the north we find
ourselves face to face with a gate of
divine prowess
it was here during the turbulent decade
known as the cultural revolution that
several groups of young red guards
responded to chairman mao's call to
quote bombard the headquarters of the
chinese communist party
one particularly zealous group of
teenagers attempted to ram through the
gate of divine prowess with a truck
when that failed they decided to hoist
the banner over the gate that read
palace of blood and tears
a few red guards did manage to make it
inside where they subjected resident
staff to struggle sessions and replaced
old plaques with mao portraits and
quotes from his little red book
but once we pass through the gate of
divine prowess all that recent upheaval
is quickly forgotten for we have entered
the imperial garden
sharing space with the garden is a
taoist temple with a statue of a
powerful god inside this is the hall of
imperial peace
together this garden and its taoist
temple represent some of the
quintessential elements of chinese
culture
taoism for instance is china's only
major indigenous religion with a focus
on achieving harmony with the natural
world and learning how to harness its
mysterious powers for the pursuit of
health and longevity
in the attics of several buildings in
the forbidden city for instance we find
evidence of taoist rituals intended to
neutralize the ever-present threat of
fire
these include tablets inscribed with the
names of various taoist deities along
with a rare fungus the linger mushroom
which was believed to aid the pursuit of
immortality when ingested
the imperial garden was also inspired by
interactions between the chinese and
nature
particularly when millions fled the
war-torn and overpopulated lands of the
yellow river valley during the second
half of the first millennium and took
refuge in the south
instead of the arid plains and dusty
plateaus of the north chinese migrants
to the south found a humid wonderland of
lakes rivers mountains wetlands and
tropical flora
wealthy landlords and officials began to
demonstrate their knowledge and
appreciation of this unfamiliar
landscape by recreating it in enclosed
artificial gardens
similarly the imperial garden in the
forbidden city is filled with imitation
hills miniature streams manicured plants
elegant kiosks and pavilions the perfect
place for cultivated gentlemen to drink
tea write poetry and reflect on man's
place in the cosmos
other elements of the forbidden city
also draw upon the philosophical and
cultural foundations of chinese
civilization
the most obvious is in the very name of
the palace itself
literally means the forbidden walled
city of the pole star
this is a reference to the ancient ideal
of a virtuous monarch
according to the 6th century bc
philosopher confucius
a virtuous monarch is like the pole star
which remains constant as all the other
celestial bodies revolve around it
then we also have the concept of feng
shui or the harmonious alignment of man
with the latent powers of nature as
embodied in the landscape
in fact feng shui is directly
responsible for the construction of
prospect hill where we started our tour
that's right i said construction
for prospect hill is an artificial mound
that is composed of the dirt and rock
dug up from the moat
according to the guiding precepts of
feng shui a man-made structure such as
the forbidden city will only be safe if
it has water in front and a protective
mountain behind it
prospect hill is that mountain while an
artificial canal known as the river of
golden waters in the southernmost
courtyard provides the water from the
imperial garden let's exit to the
southwest and make our way through what
is known as the inner court
now the fundamental spatial division in
the forbidden city is between the inner
and the outer court the outer court is
more or less the southern half of the
precinct while the inner court covers
most of the northern half
the chief difference between the two
lies not an appearance but rather in
scale and function
the halls of the outer court are much
more grandiose and imposing with vast
courtyards surrounding them on all sides
but no one lived in the outer court and
women were a rare sight there this is
because the outer court served as the
backdrop for most of the formal rituals
and imperial audiences of the empire
as we'll see when we reach the southern
half of the forbidden city
the inner court in the northern half
however was much more intimate and
personalized
here among narrow walkways tiny
courtyards private gardens and even
multi-story opera theaters lived the
emperor his women and an army of eunuchs
to serve them
as we stroll through the dense living
quarters of the northwestern section of
the inner court we'll catch a glimpse of
the western six palaces
along with the eastern six palaces these
residences would have served as the
homes of high-ranking consorts and
empress dowagers
there were eight ranks of imperial
consorts and these ranks determined
every aspect of their lives in the
forbidden city
the size of their residents their number
of servants the quality of their food
and many other markers of status
most exalted of all however were the
empress dowagers who were either mothers
or widows of emperors
they outranked even the emperor himself
who kowtowed only to her and to heaven
the palace of compassion and tranquility
just southwest of the western six
palaces was home to one of these
powerful women in the middle of the 17th
century
her name was boombatai and she was the
mongol consort of the founding emperor
of the qing dynasty
as the mother of the second emperor and
grandmother of the third she wielded
enormous influence at court
but in a deeply patriarchal society this
power had to be exercised in subtle ways
so boombatai like most imperial women in
a position of influence chose to funnel
her resources into religious patronage
for instance she transformed the
building just behind the palace of
compassion and tranquility into a great
buddha hall and it remained the center
of buddhist worship for centuries after
her death
in addition to chinese buddhism the
architecture of the inner court also
found room to accommodate the worship of
tibetan buddhism in a courtyard just
north of the palace of compassionate
tranquility is the pavilion of rain and
flowers now the most complete tibetan
tantric temple in china the pavilion of
rain and flowers can be identified by
its distinctive bronze roof
though the ming imperial court was an
eager patron of tibetan buddhism they
were unable to extend their political
influence into tibet
but the pavilion of rain and flowers did
serve as a religious symbol of chinese
imperial ambition to control tibet an
ambition that was largely realized in
the 20th century
now so far we've visited three of the
most important religious shrines in the
forbidden city but there are some 26 of
them in all each one filled with incense
candles and incantations
perhaps the most unique religious
monument however was a building that was
never intended to serve a religious
function to get there let's head back
through the western six palaces to a
large courtyard just south of the
imperial garden
this courtyard contains the three rear
palaces which mirror on a smaller scale
the three grand halls of the outer court
to the south
the furthest north of the three rear
palaces is the palace of earthly
tranquility
during the ming dynasty this palace was
the primary residence of the empress but
under the qing it was transformed into a
space for worshiping the unique manchu
gods of the royal family
from the late 17th century onward it
would have been adorned with bows
quivers and drums not only that it would
have been staffed by manchu shamans who
richly roasted a boar in specially made
pits
but you need to be careful when roasting
boars in the forbidden city the palace
of earthly tranquility burnt down and
had to be rebuilt a total of four times
now let's head to the next building in
this courtyard the hall of union
a small square structure the hall of
union was where the empress and top
consorts assembled once every year to
perform the rights of sericulture or
silk production
this was the feminine counterpart to the
masculine rights of rice agriculture
and as usual the activities undertaken
by women are confined to the inner court
so what about the men
well the only real man who could live in
the inner court was the emperor himself
he was of course attended by thousands
of eunuchs who also spent their days and
nights throughout the forbidden city
in fact historians estimate that the
ming court employed as many as 20 000
units
the qing who overthrew the ming and
regarded eunuch interference and
politics as one of their downfalls
reduced the number of eunuchs to
one-tenth that of their predecessor
and as for the son of heaven himself the
first 13 emperors of the ming dynasty
lived just south of the hall of union in
the hall of heavenly purity
then early in the morning on november 27
1542
more than a dozen women succeeded in
tying up the sadistic jajing emperor and
attempted to strangle him
they failed and suffered the ultimate
punishment ling chur
also known as the death of a thousand
cuts
the emperor badly shaken vowed never to
sleep in the hall of heavenly purity
again
but it was still used for some formal
ceremonies involving the emperor
perhaps the most famous was that of the
youngjung emperor who reigned in the
middle of the 18th century
an attempt to prevent endless scheming
over the succession process the yongjung
emperor wrote down the name of his
chosen air on two separate pieces of
paper
one was kept on his own person and the
other was hidden in the hall of heavenly
purity
so if ming and ching emperors no longer
felt safe in the hall of heavenly purity
where did they live
for the answer let's head southwest to
the adjacent hall of mental cultivation
a small underwhelming building this hall
was chosen mostly for a strategic
location
nestled on the eastern edge of the inner
court it afforded easy access to both
the women's quarters to the west and
north as well as to the grand halls of
the outer court to the southeast
these destinations were served by three
gates each with a very specific purpose
one southern gate led to the outer court
and the formal business of the empire
which we'll see in a second
two northern gates however granted
access to the women's quarters
one to the empress dowager and one to
the emperor's consorts these separate
passageways were purposely segregated so
that the empress dowager could not keep
tabs on which consort the emperor had
chosen to favor
now i think we're ready to walk in the
footsteps of the emperor himself
let's recreate a day in the life of one
of the longest reigning emperors in
chinese history the qin long emperor who
ruled more than 60 years from the 1730s
to the 1790s
on any given day he likely would have
woken up around four in the morning
after having spent the night alone in
his bed
any consort or concubine he had chosen
to spend the previous evening with would
have returned to her own quarters before
bedtime
once awake the emperor lit a candle this
was the signal to the eunuchs outside
that the curfew had ended and that the
emperor was ready for a tub of hot water
after cleaning himself up the emperor
made his first stop at the palace of
earthly tranquility
after listening to the shamanic dirges
and witnessing the roasting of a boar he
was carried in a sedan chair to the west
flourishing gate in the far southwestern
corner of the palace
here he exited the forbidden city and
entered what are today known as the lake
palaces
first built by the mongol yen dynasty in
the 13th century the lake palaces are a
series of pavilions and halls situated
along the scenic shores of zhongnanghai
the central and southern lakes
here in the studio of convivial delights
chienlong ate his breakfast some 18
dishes spread out over four tables with
four eunuchs attending to his every need
after breakfast the rest of the day was
devoted to work
first the emperor would probably return
to the hall of mental cultivation or the
palace of heavenly purity in the inner
court where he would read government
documents and meet with his top military
and civil officials
but sooner or later he would make his
way to the hall of supreme harmony in
the outer court
this is where the formal and most solemn
business of the empire took place
with the largest dimensions of any
building in the empire the hall of
supreme harmony is the most impressive
and imposing structure in the forbidden
city
it stands about 114 feet tall and spans
a width of nearly 200 feet
along with two other smaller halls
behind it
the hall of supreme harmony sits on a
three-tiered marble platform that
symbolizes mount sumeru the buddhist
mountain at the center of the cosmos
but the emperor had his own special
stairway for this platform one that only
he could cross over in a sedan chair
known as the cinnabar stairway it is a
single block of inclined marble that
weighs 250 tons
carvings of dragons playing with pearls
decorate its surface
scholars estimate that nearly 6 000
soldiers and 10 000 laborers were
required to transport this slab of
marble from a quarry about 30 miles away
now the hall of supreme harmony was the
primary venue for all major imperial
rituals and ceremonies these included
the emperor's birthday
his enthronement
audiences with foreign delegations and
the final round of the civil service
examination
the setting was ideal for mass assembly
the courtyard just south of the hall of
supreme harmony covers seven and a half
acres or just a little more than two
baseball fields
but the hall of supreme harmony while
impressive is not the only building in
this courtyard immediately behind it to
the north is the smaller hall of central
harmony where the emperor could rest or
change his clothing between audiences
and behind that is the somewhat larger
hall of preserved harmony which hosted
large banquets for foreign dignitaries
and various other celebrations
sometime in the late afternoon or early
evening the never-ending business of
tending to the empire finally came to an
end
when the work day was over the emperor
would likely retire to one of his
pleasure gardens back inside the inner
court
we know that the qin long emperor
favored the studio of exhausted
diligence in the northeastern corner
the name of the garden says it all this
is where you go after a long day of
exhausting diligence at work
this particular garden complex has been
extensively renovated in recent years so
it gives visitors a pretty good idea of
how the emperor spent his leisure hours
it includes picturesque pavilions
man-made ponds manicured trees and hills
and even an indoor theater
but we're going to pretend that today is
a special day so we're not going to let
chen long retire to his gardens
for on march 12 1760 there was still
some state business he had to attend to
that was the day when chen long reviewed
a parade of soldiers who had just
returned from a grand military conquest
on the northwestern frontiers of the
empire
the preferred staging grounds for such
occasions was just south of the meridian
gate
now the starting point for most tourists
who enter the complex the meridian gate
is actually the tallest structure in the
forbidden city with three passageways at
ground level
on this particular day chen long would
have assumed his place at the center of
the parapets on top of the gate and
taken in the site below
his troops had just returned from the
muslim lands of central asia
and placed by the emperor's side was a
casket containing
two left ears of the final muslim
belligerence
and with these grisly trophies in hand
chen long could finally retire to the
inner court having unknowingly laid the
foundations for the modern day
boundaries of the people's republic of
china
the 20th century was not kind to the
forbidden city in the year 1900 it was
invaded and plundered by eight foreign
empires who auctioned off many of its
treasures
after the 1911 revolution and abdication
of the last qing emperor most modern
chinese statesmen viewed it as an
unwelcome reminder of feudal china and
the political and cultural stagnation
that they blamed for china's repeated
defeats at the hands of foreign powers
after the chinese communists came to
power in 1949
chairman mao even considered various
proposals to demolish the forbidden city
and replace it with modern highways or
stalinist style architecture
but none of these rulers could ever
quite bring themselves to tear its
ancient buildings down
instead china's new leaders took up
residence in jiangnanghai or the lake
palaces located just outside the western
walls where the chenglong emperor used
to eat his daily breakfast
today zhong nanghai is practically a
synonym for the highest levels of
communist party leadership
this seems to be a metaphor for china's
newfound embrace of its imperial past
wary of following directly in the
footsteps of the emperors they instead
founded new organs of government in the
shadow of their greatest imperial palace
today the forbidden city is a national
museum
as such it serves a very different
purpose than before
that is once quite literally forbidden
to the chinese people
today the forbidden city is held up as
the very emblem of the chinese nation
itself
no doubt the chen long emperor is
rolling in his grave
but such is the inevitable fate of any
building that manages to survive two
dynasties endless wars a host of
termites endless roasting of boars and a
communist revolution
to paraphrase the emperor's eunuchs when
they greeted him each morning
long live the forbidden city
[Music]
you